look like the cost of crap friends can
be expensive just like the cost of
inviting the wrong woman into your life
can be expensive there's there's a price
to pay
um
you want to
vet as thoroughly as possible but you're
not using the same red flag system that
I've devised and put in the first book
to sort of establish whether or not
she's the kind of woman that you want to
avoid in your life because
um is slightly different I mean there's
some similarities again I mean you
wouldn't want to have friends that are
violent you know they get a bad temper
um but their Notch count doesn't matter
you know you don't care if they've run
around for you know 10 years with a
bunch of gals that that's really not
that significant to be honest with you
um maybe your rabies and a few of the
others but
if you're not attentive to the guys that
you hang out with they will drag you
down I've talked about anchors and sales
we're getting on the vetting section but
I've but I've gotten involved with so
one two three four probably five or six
different dudes that have
made
intentional moves towards complicating
my life unnecessarily and the character
and the show of character is a leading
indicator of the kind of person in your
world and I'll just share some personal
stories you know without giving away
specific details and names obviously but
the types of guys that you're going to
run into out there they're always a lot
of fun you know you're gonna you're
gonna meet them in your younger years or
a good laugh you drink with them you
know you party with them sort of thing
you might start going to the gym with
them you're working out they're going to
threaten a tea bag if you don't push the
weight harder you know you guys hang out
you might start riding motorcycles
together spending late nights you know
through four o'clock in the morning
racing doing all kinds of stuff riding
ramps drinking you know coffees and
stuff like that and ripping up and down
the roads in the middle of the night
these kind of guys you know will seem
like a lot of fun you know you go out
and pick up girls together
um I did loads of this stuff you know my
20s on the motorcycles we you know we'd
have a spare helmet throw them on the
back sort of thing
um they're like my brother from another
mother
they are and that's where you get to but
if you're but if you're not attentive to
the sort of character that they have and
you look past negative traits
um I did this myself like I had a friend
that
um did some underhanded stuff for being
honest
um these people drag you down man like
things like you know he would tell me
stories proudly how you know he would go
over to his friend's place or his mom
you know would be around she's of course
divorced you know single and ready to
mingle sort of thing
had him had the other friend when she
was younger and he would bang his
friend's mom
and you know proudly boast about it he
would um you know go out and about and
bang friends uh girlfriends
um if they were in a fight or something
like that or a little bit of a scrap or
a break we were on a break
um you know he he he'd snake his way in
you know he basically worm his way into
her pants sort of thing that's those are
all pretty strong indicators of
character right
um there's got to be some sort of moral
compass or boundary when it comes to
dudes when you invite him into your life
and I think that and I've said this
before you know you can't trust guys
that can't get laid and you can't trust
guys that are obsessed about getting
late I mean if they're at the point
where they're banging other friends moms
or they're banging you know other
friends girlfriends sort of thing
um that's some questionable behavior and
it should be a strong indicator this
isn't somebody that you want to spend a
great deal of time with travel with uh
bring into a business you know that you
might be running
um these are all things that might seem
entertaining eating and fun when you're
having good laughs and you're sitting
around late at night you know chuckling
about life and oh yeah you know we'll be
doing this when we're 90 years old and
you know clicking your cans together
sort of thing
it might seem comfortable it might seem
convenient but who are these guys you
know
um I'll tell you exactly who they are
because I've had friends like this and
they're the kind of guys that will bang
your girlfriend they're the kind of guys
that
um will want to get involved in your
business dealings for example you know
if they see you doing things
putting bigger and bigger dents in the
universe and essentially you know
starting to pulling some some bucks
Deluxe like you're making some bank and
they want a piece of that pie they'll
worm their way in you know oh yeah you
know I've got capabilities I've got
skills I'll go and do it I'm telling you
like I've seen guys do that and you know
you bring them in on your Biz you know
you bring them in on projects you're
working on
there's the old saying baffles
brains and uh they'll start uh
strategizing and planning
behind the scenes and doing things to
sort of um how can I put it we'll just
say jeopardize your business you know in
your BR you know your business model
compete against you steal clients steal
contracts stuff like that
the moral character of somebody will be
on display
you want a guy that you can trust you
can't trust a guy that's banging your
friend's moms you just can't
sure have a laugh about it but you can't
trust the guy I mean is this somebody
that you would want to have around your
family that you'd want to invite over to
dinner that you'd want around your kids
want around your daughter even
absolutely not you know these are these
are moral judgments that you have to
make
you got to size people up you got to get
good at sizing people if you if you
can't size people up if you can't
evaluate what they're made of you know
the you know the fabric of their being
then why are you hanging around these
people like these are basic skills okay
um
you know one of the things that we've
talked about before is
before you get too serious with the
check
you want to spend like a year or two
with her to see what she's made of you
know when stress is applied to that
relationship like you travel somewhere
and your luggage gets lost does she have
a total meltdown did she start yelling
at the airline at the stewardess and all
that sort of thing or does she say I
don't worry about it let's go to the
store and you know grab some bathing
suits and a few things and we'll be fine
for the rest of the week sort of thing
we'll deal with the luggage later right
it's the same sort of thing with guys
you know with friends right like are
they are they an anchor or are they a
sale so let's get into
you know the vetting component right
because this is straight up easy you
know once you once you get a good handle
like this is stuff that I wish that I do
in my 20s
that I only figured out probably in the
last decade or two right and
it cost me lawsuits right suing friends
that did underhanding things to try to
ruin business try to steal business try
to steal customer contracts and clients
and things like that it costs you
sleepless nights you know like you will
be betrayed by women in your life and
you will be betrayed by friends if you
let it happen but if you're and I'm not
saying build walls around yourself but
I'm saying learn how to size people up
right like see what they're made of see
how they behave in scenarios where you'd
expect them to have your back like one
of the most important things that I've
and I've said this many many times
before guys is
you're very good friends your absolute
best friends will talk to your face
nice shirt does it come in men's ah nice
car too bad it's too slow
you see what I'm saying right like
they'll like they'll talk to your
face but every single time you guys are
apart right he's always got your back
that's a strong leaning indicator
now again
um moff is in the green room area so if
you guys have a question you're going to
want to get that stream yard link
clicked at the top and get yourself
squared away for the Q a segment to make
sure your audio is good and all that
he'll be able to test it out before we
go live but we'll do it after the ad
break
so again
let's go through the points with uh
vetting
well let's deal with the anchors and
sales again anchor sales straightforward
stuff dealing with the sailboat you know
me it's one of the things that I pay
attention to is up as I'm getting older
into the Autumn years definitely want to
get on water more especially in the
Caribbean especially in the
Mediterranean it's going to happen
anchors and sales anchors hold you you
drop the hook in the water
it's it's supposed to prevent you from
moving around a little bit of slippage
but again it's supposed to prevent you
from moving around people have to go
into these two categories you know these
these friends of yours the business
associates whatever it is that you
happen to be rolling with they have to
go in one of the two categories anchors
or sales are they holding you back are
they holding you in place are they
allowing you to move to your next Port
of Call right to your next destinations
as you as you progress through that
passage right are they anchors or are
they sales
next point
average of the five you're going to
spend the most time with said this
before and I'm going to keep hammering
on this because it's so important take a
look at the people around you your five
closest friends that you spend the five
not even five let's just say the people
that you spend the most time with
could be three of them could be five of
them but the people that you spend the
most time with will rub off on you and
you will become the average of those
people you spend time with five broke
dumb losers that are doing absolutely
nothing with their life they're
incompetent they're a bad moral
character you will become the six it is
impossible absolutely impossible to soar
like an eagle if you surround yourself
with turkeys
do not surround yourself with turkeys
take a look at the five people you're
spending the most time with right now
and categorize them
I'm serious categorizing are they
contributing to the best version of
yourself
are they helping you move along
to get to the better version of yourself
do they support that better version of
yourself if you paint a picture and you
say
I'm not riding sport bikes anymore I
need a
Lambo
I'm going to go out and do this this and
this to go get the lambo are they all
about yeah
I'm down with that man
let's move up the ladder let's move up
to the next level let's start doing this
that or the other thing let's go beyond
just
this area here let's go up to this area
here are they are they moving into these
categories do they do they contribute to
the best version of yourself
straightforward question it's not
complex right
are they supporting and facilitating
dreams and goals that you're setting if
you deviate from them let's say you know
you've set a very clear and concise goal
and if you deviate from them are they
saying yo hold on a second hold you
accountable what are you doing this for
over here if it's not aligned with what
you said you wanted to do over there
that's a good friend that's somebody
that you'd want to bring along with you
that's a sale that's going to help you
move along you know that passage your
next Port of Call right facilitating and
supporting the dreams and goals and
holding you accountable hold you
accountable is huge man you know guys
that are all like oh I'm going to lose
weight or I'm going to develop a strong
muscular uh physique frame or I'm going
to get into uh boxing and have a fight
or whatever it happens to be
cool are they sparring with you are they
going to the gym with you are when
you're on the bench press
um and you're at your one rep max are
they throwing on another two and a half
pounds on either side and spotting you
on that and threatened a teabag you if
you don't get the weight back up to the
top are they those guys you know are
they holding you accountable afterwards
when you leave the gym to go get
something to eat and they say nah you
know we can't go to McDonald's we gotta
go get some proper uh chicken and rice
over here at this place right because
that's what you want
that's how you should be evaluating the
friends that you surround yourself with
are you guys on the same path are you on
the same mission
right are you holding you guys are you
holding each other accountable to these
standards to get to those goals you know
what they are
you know people are well how do you lose
weight
move more eat better
that's a summary
move more as far as lifting heavy things
picking them up and putting them back
down you want to get better at uh
Realms of combat pick up boxing whatever
it you know you want to happen to do
and start going with the guys
get some gloves and some mitts and go
out to the park and train skip rope
before you're training together push
yourself from four minutes to five
minutes next you know next month it's
five minutes to Six Minutes of skipping
rope before you get started
and again I think one of the most
important indicators and as you get
older and you get into relationships or
if you have kids and you have family
events I've seen this like I've seen
some of the shittiest people
that I know they don't have
good interactions with family
some of the best people that I know like
some of the best Souls that I know
they've got great family and family is
always there for them and they're there
to support and they're the kind of
people it's like you know you can bring
your family into or you can bring your
kids into those environments and room
and you can trust them there right like
is this is this somebody that I can
leave my daughter in a room with and
feel comfortable and confident
everything is good and and if somebody
breaks into the house they're going to
protect that kid and defend the home and
the child from the Intruder sort of
thing like is that the kind of friend
that you're bringing along it's
important to contemplate it's really
important man I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out